we welcome the co-host of the hit show
The Five our very own Judge Jeanine
Pirro is here
it's great to see you
oh by the way I did not get that
reaction when I came out I'm just saying
it's great to see you congratulations on
all your success okay I want to start
with a different question okay so Abby
Lowe who got John Edwards off and Abby
Lowell who got uh Senator Menendez off
is now the Biden's attorney he's one of
the best attorneys in the country I
think you would admit okay he's
representing them so this is not a slam
dunk is it
let me ask you a question
by the way behind me it says Piro I
didn't know that okay
if if you uh sign a pistol permit
application and you lie on that
application go to jail and you get the
permit you get the gun what else do you
need I don't care if God comes down and
represents you you are guilty of lying
and submitting a perjurious statement
for a gun
we're we're asking do we have a dual
justice system in America of course if
it was Sean Hannity uh I would I would
have been in jail already me too I
know okay but here's the thing at least
I have a friend yeah
no but you'd have to identify as female
to get into my jail be a whole thing uh
but yeah
I have now lost I I have lost all
control of this show go ahead okay but
here's the problem America has lost
faith in the criminal justice system for
good reason I gave 32 years of my life
as a prosecutor or judge in a D.A I
believe in this system I'm a Believer
but I have lost faith for good reason we
watched Jim Comey of the FBI not the
Attorney General say Hillary Clinton
didn't commit a crime that anyone could
prove I could prove it you could prove
it okay and then we see the Attorney
General today called parents domestic
terrorists because they're concerned
about their kids one parent in
particular whose daughter was raped in
school and they didn't want to admit it
okay people can protest in front of
Supreme Court Justices homes and not be
arrested on a statute that is clear on
its face that requires an arrest now I'm
not going to go on and on but there's a
reason there's a reason no no no no no
no no I want to answer the question
we're talking about violation of tax
laws we're talking about foreign
lobbying we're talking about money
laundering and we're talking about lying
on Episcopal permit application now this
whole thing started with the treasury
Department submitting 150 transactions
that they thought were unusual usually
related to tax evasion or money
laundering now related to China and
foreign countries now foreign foreign
Pharaoh the the foreign
that you're a lobbyist in other
countries now Paul manafort went to jail
for 60 months for that and they're
saying we don't know if we can prove
that Hunter knew we were supposed to
register as a foreign
should be applied right but he didn't
but he knew he had more reason to know
than anyone because in one of the email
violate pharah
so about pharah right there you've got a
crime you've got a crime with the
lobbying and you've got a crime with a
gun and you also have the crime tax
evasion I know people who've gone to
jail after they paid their taxes I do
okay he paid his taxes why isn't he
going to jail for two million dollars
shouldn't she be the AG I think
judge yeah I'm gonna bring in the
audience
it's very hard for me to book the judge
on this show don't you think she should
be on at least twice a week
why is it so hard yes at nine o'clock I
will all right judge thank you congrats
we love having you yeah we love you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else